The first live-action Justice League was always
going to feature lots of plot development
to properly establish a team-up between DC
Comics legends.
But with its four-hour-runtime, Zack Snyder's
Justice League is jam-packed with world building
heading into its final act.
"Isn't that right … Batman?"
Here's the ending of the Snyder Cut, explained.
Zack Snyder's Justice League is not short
on story.
The film establishes the individual worlds
of newbie superheroes like Cyborg, Aquaman,
and the Flash, while also depicting a world
still reeling from the demise of Superman
at the end of Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice.
In these earlier scenes, Snyder and company
establish the personality traits of our superhero
protagonists that will end up being crucial
in the film's climax.
For example, we're introduced to a forlorn
Cyborg, still unsure of what to do with his
new robotic enhancements.
Barry Allen, meanwhile, is stuck doing dead-end
jobs to help pursue a criminal law degree
so he can get his dad, Henry, out of prison.
The individual members of the titular Justice
League have very different personal problems
to work out.
However, a recurring trait across Cyborg and
Aquaman's storylines is a lack of interest
in working as a team player.
Despite those doubts, all of these heroes
are forced to work together once Steppenwolf
begins assembling the Mother Boxes to destroy
Earth.
It's a threat so intimidating that the team
decides to use one of the Mother Boxes to
resurrect Superman, a figure powerful enough
to help defeat this otherworldly entity.
By the time the finale begins, the Justice
League has headed off to Russia to confront
their cosmic enemy, and Superman has come
back to life and is regaining his personality
by sharing tender moments with Lois Lane.
Will this epic resurrection pay off in the
end?
"It has to."
Every member of the Justice League has a critical
role to play in the final confrontation against
Steppenwolf, and Barry Allen is no exception.
In order for Cyborg to access the trio of
Mother Boxes, he'll require a shock of electricity
that can only be generated by the Flash running
at an incredibly high level of speed.
While engaging in that kind of run, the Flash
is shot down by a Parademon soldier.
With our hero briefly knocked aside, Darkseid
and his forces are given enough time to activate
the Mother Boxes and destroy Earth.
But just as the planet is being annihilated,
the Flash decides to break his one rule and
run so fast that he ends up going back in
time.
It's a risky move that the superhero isn't
sure he'll be able to survive, but he has
no choice if he wants to save the world.
While running at such an extreme velocity,
the Flash remembers his father's remark that
his son was "the best of the best," and Barry
realizes that he's finally lived up to that
moniker.
In the end, his daunting run pays off enormously,
as time is turned back just enough so Flash
can give Cyborg that electrical boost, thus
cementing the world's safety.
However, it also gives Barry Allen the revelation
that he is indeed capable of traveling through
time, an ability that's gotten the character
into plenty of trouble in comic book storylines
like Flashpoint.
Much like in the theatrical cut of Justice
League, Zack Snyder's version sees Superman
returning from the dead, briefly turning evil,
and then restoring his original personality
just in time to stop Steppenwolf from destroying
Earth.
In Snyder's version, though, the transition
takes longer to happen.
The biggest deviation between the films is
an extended scene in Zack Snyder's Justice
League depicting Superman returning to his
Fortress of Solitude before he reunites with
the Justice League.
The resurrected Kryptonian walks around the
halls of his lair while the voices of his
two fathers, Jor-El and Johnathan Kent, speak
to him about the importance of pursuing who
he wants to be.
By the end of this sequence, Superman is wearing
a black version of his traditional superhero
suit, and he flies away, ready to join the
Justice League.
When he does, he manages to get there just
in the nick of time.
Steppenwolf's axe is about to land on Cyborg
when Superman intervenes.
Using his superpowered breath to turn the
axe into ice, Superman makes his powerful
presence apparent, and he and Steppenwolf
proceed to have a duel.
This confrontation ends with Superman pinning
the beast to the ground and punching him repeatedly.
Superman returned to this world unsure of
where he stood or who he was.
As he fights Steppenwolf for the good of humanity,
it becomes apparent that the Man of Steel
has become the protector he was always meant
to be.
In the final battle against Steppenwolf's
forces, Cyborg takes it upon himself to disconnect
the three Mother Boxes, thus preventing Earth's
destruction.
His ability to tap into any piece of technology
means he has the best chance of dismantling
these objects and foiling Steppenwolf's plan.
Wonder Woman makes it apparent, though, that
there is a risk to this.
While Cyborg is tapping into them, the Mother
Boxes will exploit his fears in an attempt
to stop him.
And that's just what happens once Cyborg gets
inside the Mother Boxes and sees a vision
of his parents, Silas and Elinore.
They stand there with a fully healed version
of Cyborg and urge their son to stop fighting.
It's a scenario designed to tap into Cyborg's
insecurities and stop him from disconnecting
those Mother Boxes.
But our hero isn't backing down now.
Cyborg continues his mission with the help
of his Justice League comrades.
The young man who once sat in his apartment
alone and unsure of where he fit in this world
has now come to accept his new form, his new
friends and his new purpose on the planet.
It's also a sequence that fulfills earlier
rumors that Cyborg would be getting a much
greater spotlight in Zack Snyder's Justice
League.
All of the members of the Justice League have
a bone to pick with Steppenwolf, given that
he's keen on eradicating the planet they call
home.
However, Wonder Woman develops her own personal
animosity with this Apokolips resident after
an intense mid-movie interaction.
Here, Steppenwolf reveals that he slaughtered
many of Wonder Woman's Amazonian allies in
his pursuit of the Mother Box that was once
held on the island.
Enraged at the thought of Themyscira's finest
warriors dying at his hands, Wonder Woman's
quest for revenge against Steppenwolf is initiated.
Once the final battle arrives, Wonder Woman
leads Aquaman and Cyborg to a personal confrontation
with Steppenwolf.
Here, the alien once again taunts Wonder Woman
with how many Amazonian's he's killed, all
the while reminding her that she could've
saved them if she hadn't abandoned her home
for the world of man.
Enraged, Wonder Woman begins to brutally fight
back against the villain and even bangs her
bracelets on her shield to create an explosion
that sends Steppenwolf spinning.
Eventually, after the other members of the
Justice League join in to fight this monster,
Wonder Woman gets her revenge.
The final move that kills this minion of Darkseid
is Wonder Woman slicing off his head with
her sword.
With the flick of a blade, Wonder Woman has
honored the memories of her fallen Amazonian
comrades.
Zack Snyder's Justice League ends on many
teases of things to come, with one of those
involving Darkseid.
Seen throughout the movie as the intimidating
superior and nephew of Steppenwolf, Darkseid
has been firmly established as someone you
don't want to cross.
This reputation is reaffirmed in the film's
climactic scene, which involves Darkseid witnessing
Steppenwolf's defeat at the hands of the Justice
League.
Shortly afterwards, his second-in-command,
DeSaad, notes that he always knew Steppenwolf
would fail.
But despite this setback, Darkseid has already
got his eyes set on the future.
Now knowing that the Anti-Life Equation is
built into the planet, Darkseid intends to
pursue Earth again, this time with more extreme
force.
Darkseid references "the armada" and "the
old ways," referring to an earlier flashback
that showed him leading a massive army to
destroy Earth, just as he had done with thousands
of planets before.
At the time, he was stopped by the combined
forces of Amazonians, Atlanteans, mortal men,
gods, and a Green Lantern warrior.
Now, he intends to lead such an army again
to Earth to face off against the newly united
Justice League.
As Darkseid lurches out of frame in his final
scene in the Snyder Cut, it becomes apparent
that this moment functions to further solidify
the ruler of Apokolips as a formidable threat
in a potential Justice League follow-up.
Zack Snyder's Justice League concludes with
an epilogue entitled "A Father Twice Over."
The title refers to a line said by Silas Stone
to his son in a pre-recorded message, where
he mentions that, through being his biological
father and giving him his robotic enhancements,
he's Cyborg's father in more ways than one.
Stone's monologue to his son about the importance
of pursuing your own path in this world plays
over a montage showing where all the members
of the Justice League are in the wake of defeating
Steppenwolf.
Aquaman meets up with Mera and Vulko, who
are both grateful for this half-Atlantean's
part in saving the world.
Meanwhile, Bruce Wayne uses his enormous wealth
to buy up the bank that foreclosed on Clark
Kent's childhood farmhouse home.
Barry Allen has also managed to score a job
at a crime lab in his home of Central City,
much to his incarcerated father's delight.
Most importantly, though, is that Wayne buys
up a building to serve as a headquarters for
the Justice League and their activities, complete
with a large round table that, quote, "has
chairs for six ... but room for more."
Both the building and the table echo the team's
classic Hall of Justice location, and the
reference to the group expanding its roster
in the future is an acknowledgement of how
so many DC Superheroes have come and gone
from the Justice League in the comics.
Zack Snyder's Justice League concludes with
a trio of standalone sequences that help to
set up future adventures for its principal
characters.
The first of these scenes is one that will
be familiar to anyone who saw the mid-credits
sequence in the theatrical cut of Justice
League.
The rendezvous between Lex Luthor and Deathstroke
is retained here and begins like it does in
the original version, with an Arkham Asylum
guard discovering that Luthor has broken out
of his cell.
We then cut to Deathstroke emerging onto the
billionaire's yacht, which is where the Snyder
Cut differs from the theatrical version.
Originally, this sequence revolved around
Luther hinting at the formation of the Legion
of Doom.
"To put it plainly, shouldn't we have a league
of our own?"
Here, Luthor calls upon Deathstroke — who
harnesses a grudge against Batman — to divulge
the news that Gotham's Dark Knight is actually
Bruce Wayne.
It's info that gets the grizzled Deathstroke
to smile and announce that there's reason
to celebrate.
Apparently, this whole scene was meant to
serve as a set-up for Ben Affleck's proposed
solo Batman movie, which would've seen Deathstroke
serve as its principal antagonist.
But in the years since this post-credit scene
was filmed, things have changed drastically
for Batman's big-screen plans.
We know Ben Affleck's character is returning
for The Flash, but past that, we're unsure
of what's in store for the Caped Crusader,
especially with Robert Pattinson running around.
However, this initial tease has been restored
in Zack Snyder's Justice League to offer fans
a taste of what could've been and, hopefully,
what can be again.
The second of the Snyder Cut's closing scenes
returns to a familiar locale from Batman v
Superman: Dawn of Justice – Batman's "Knightmare"
landscape.
This particular voyage to the post-apocalyptic
location sees Batman joined by a gaggle of
companions, including Justice League members
Flash and Cyborg, Mera, Deathstroke, and Jared
Leto's Joker.
The scene begins with Mera discussing her
desire to murder those responsible for killing
Aquaman before asking Batman how he could
possibly know what it's like to lose a loved
one.
This leads to a chat between Joker and Batman,
with the former goading the Dark Knight over
the loss of his parents.
To retort, Batman recalls how he held a dying
Harley Quinn in his arms while she said to
kill the Joker.
These conflict-ridden allies are suddenly
greeted by a figure from Batman's previous
Knightmare experience — an evil, twisted
version of Superman.
Now working for Darkseid, this Superman fires
laser beam blasts from his eyes at the team
before Bruce Wayne suddenly awakens in the
present day from his vision.
Not only does this closing sequence follow
up on threads and characters from prior DCEU
movies, but it's also a glimpse at what Zack
Snyder once envisioned for the franchise's
future.
According to Snyder, Justice League 2 would've
been largely set within this Knightmare landscape.
While that follow-up remains an unlikely proposition,
this closing scene in the Snyder Cut offers
a glimpse of what could've been.
With Zack Snyder's Justice League, die-hard
fans of the DCEU finally got to see Harry
Lennix's Man of Steel character, Calvin Swanwick,
reveal himself as the superhero Martian Manhunter.
Fans had long suspected Swanwick's identity,
and the rumor was finally confirmed by Snyder
in 2019.
However, it seemed destined to become an obscure
"what if" scenario.
But with the release of the Snyder Cut, the
casting became a reality.
This big reveal is first realized in the movie
through an earlier moment where Martian Manhunter
takes on the form of Ma Kent to encourage
Lois Lane.
The extraterrestrial superhero then returns
in the very last scene of the entire film.
This sequence begins with Bruce Wayne, shaken
awake from a Knightmare vision, walking out
of his house to see Martian Manhunter floating
above.
The otherworldly hero notes that he and Wayne
are both aware that Darkseid is not finished
with Earth.
With impending doom on the horizon, as well
as being inspired by the Justice League, Martian
Manhunter has decided to engage in superheroics
for the sake of protecting this planet once
again.
The scene concludes with Martian Manhunter
telling Bruce Wayne that his parents would
be proud of him for assembling the Justice
League, and then he reveals his name to the
billionaire.
It's a moment that not only pays off Swanwick's
presence in previous Snyder DCEU movies but
also sets up Martian Manhunter as a potential
participant for any future DCEU efforts.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.